what happened it's gotta be something  big you were crazy about him two days  ago he's got a wife okay he's married  all right go ahead say it so we need to  know when you going to marry miss Brenda  yes no guys this is not what you asked  in America strange then I guess so much  Malgus so much anger listen I can see  that I see you don't want to be here yes  your scares you don't know what's  happening to you I can see that you  don't want to hurt anybody gonna be  alright got a clear shot not even yeah  like when you called the cops you  violated the circle of trust stalker  we're sorry we called the cops okay are  you talking to me yes yes are you  talking to me yes  300-meter toxics target  you